it derives from the Rye Lopez if you're
going to play Knights F6 they Castle on
the king side and then you play The Very
Odd move Knight to G4
second reason I like is once you
actually get this to land it's just one
of the more satisfying things you'll
ever play in chess they will usually
play H3 you're trying to kick your
knight back off and you play H5 says I
do not care what you're doing go ahead
and take them a night that's fine if
they do this you attack the night Knight
comes back to E1 and then Queen H4 and
there's no way to stop mate from here
you're threatening the queen coming up
here to H1 or H2 if they try to open up
for their King to move on this F2 Pawn
or F2 score it doesn't really matter you
just play G3 and then there's going to
be a mate followed shortly thereafter
even if they don't play E1 you still
have a lot of attacking opportunities